so friend of mine is actually a police
dispatcher and when he got out of this
movie he said wow that was like a
hundred percent authentic and I suddenly
grew an immense respect for police
officers end of watch stars Jake
Gyllenhaal and Michael Pena now these
are two guys who are police officers and
it's filmed in a very found-footage
esque style it's not supposed to be like
the footage was found or something it's
just it's filmed in that handheld style
people are walking around with cameras
like cops it's like an elongated episode
of cops and these two guys are partners
and a lot of the movie is them just
driving around answering different calls
also Jake Gyllenhaal's met this really
cute girl Anna Kendrick who really is
really adorable like like just just that
was me squeezing her cheeks okay and
Michael Pina has a wife with a baby on
the way and you really start to feel for
these guys all the while there's this
drug cartel that's rising in the area
and they begin to be a huge threat to
the police officers and it leads to a
lot of drama and emotional impact and I
mean that end of watch is really a great
movie I was blown away and completely
surprised by this movie I actually had
tickets for this in Toronto at the
Toronto Film Festival and I just was
like I'll just see it when it comes out
I could have seen it with the actors I
didn't even it's very disappointing
because this movie is actually great the
hyper-realistic filming style really
adds something to this movie it's not a
gimmick it's not used like let's just do
this and it'll be fun all shaky in your
face and we're gonna make it all you
know gritty and everything but no it
just felt so authentic and real and very
disturbing at times this is definitely
not a movie for the faint of heart let's
just put it that way you don't like
seeing disturbing imagery you may have a
problem with this movie the best part of
this movie by far is these two lead
actors this is in my opinion one of Jake
Gyllenhaal's best performances I really
think that both of these guys delivered
Oscar caliber material here they just
worked so well together he just bought
it you just totally bought these guys
are cops you forgot you know that these
guys are actors I mean you're aware of
who you're watching and you know you
understand that but they just they fit
into their roles so well and another
thing that really surprised me about
this movie is how funny it is it's
actually pretty hilarious these guys
their banter with one another when
they're not doing anything in the police
car you know they razz each other back
and forth it's so well-written
is very realistic extremely well acted
it's cleverly made in the middle of this
movie I specifically remember apart in
my head where I just went man I really
actually men to this movie I really want
to know what's gonna happen to these
guys because a lot of movies today are
really well-made but it's just so rare
anymore
to see a movie with characters that you
truly care about well-written people
that seem realistic and you're like yes
I like these guys you know and according
to my friend who's a police dispatcher
it's very authentic so good job
filmmakers I'm gonna give end of watch
and a - I hope you guys get to see it
great performances really exciting movie
but like I said not for the faint of
heart
pretty disturbing at times thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this then you can click right here
and get stuck menage